welcome back much of the mainstream
media has been in a lather at the
prospect that former national security
adviser Mike Flynn may flip against his
former boss President Trump just look at
some of these headlines ABC news Flynn's
lawyer meets members of special counsels
team raising specter of plea deal Vanity
Fair as Mike Flynn already flipped on
Trump New York Times a split from Trump
indicates that Flynn's moving forward to
cooperate with Muller is that actually
the case joining us now renowned legal
expert Harvard Law prof emeritus Alan
Dershowitz hi professor Dershowitz how
are you very good is this really it
seems like the way it's being portrayed
it's the end for Donald Trump you know
the impeachment Gallo's are waiting for
him Mike Flynn because of his work with
perhaps what he did with Turkey might
somehow mean that he's flipping on Trump
what could be going on here
well I think if he were actually
flipping on Trump and if he had made a
deal with Muller we'd never know about
it nobody would leak that information
part of the deal would be that you have
to keep this absolutely secret
I think the question nobody has been
asking is who's leaked this and why have
they leaked this look I know his lawyer
by reputation
and what his lawyer I think is doing is
offering his client for sale or at least
for rent what he's saying is he's up for
grabs
if the Trump administration wants him
they can have him just give him a pardon
and if the Trump administration doesn't
give him a pardon we're available to
make a deal with the special counsel but
I don't think the special counsel is
ready to make a deal yet because it's
not clear that fin Flynn has anything to
offer first of all his credibility is
worthless he's already been accused of
perjury second he's a witness that's
been bought or at least rented any
decent defense attorney could shred him
by saying he'd sell you his mother he's
trying to save his son he's trying to
save himself he'll say anything he'll
not only sing he'll compose and create
evidence if he has to do that in order
to get a deal so I don't think we're
anywhere close to where the media has
portrayed Flynn and a deal with Muller
and
all these months later all this time
later they're bringing in people more
people from the Trump campaign including
hope Hicks and in the in the White House
Council professor Dershowitz and people
have to understand that the White House
Council does not share an attorney
privilege with the president not a
personal privilege he does they do share
an institutional privilege that
executive privilege yeah but what what
could that pose as far as problems for
the administration well first of all I
think we might house counsel I think the
administration is not aggressive enough
with Muller they should be in court
challenging what Muller has been doing
he's going so far beyond any possible
scope of his investigation for example
do reports the other day that they were
investigating whether Jared Kushner
tried to get the United States to change
its policy toward Israel the Obama
administration which was going to allow
the resolution condemning Israel for
occupying the western wall the holiest
place in Judaism let's assume that Jared
Kushner did that he should be praised
for it there's nothing criminal about
that what is Muller doing investigating
whether or not somebody during the
transition was trying to influence
American foreign policy to the benefit
of the American people so I think the
Trump administration ought to be more
aggressive in challenging the scope of
this investigation challenging subpoenas
challenging who's called as witnesses
this is supposed to be a narrow
investigation about whether or not there
was illegal unlawful collusion with
Russia collusion itself is not a crime
but now what they're doing is going
after people for what is the equivalent
of jaywalking did they sign the right
form did they include this in the forum
that's all I attempt to try to squeeze
them into testifying against the Oval
Office but I'm in the big vise and in
turn that turned the Vice round but why
are they not being aggressive I'm this
ty cobb guy who's a I'm not sure I'm
wild about Ty Cobb representing the
president mean he's a good one the guy
who was eaten at the restaurant and
talking loudly about strategy
I shouldn't be doing that he says he has
a very good reputation okay as a good
lawyer and no lawyer should be
second-guessing their strategy without
knowing what's actually going on but
it's so obvious that Muller is going
well beyond the scope of what his
authority was I read the letter the
letter authorizing his investigation and
what he's done in some of the witnesses
is called and certainly wasn't
subpoenaed he's now you know subpoenaing
things that are so far beyond the scope
of the investigation hi Cobb not Ty Cobb
or the president's legal team not
challenging this I mean that's the
question and that's the question and
also look the other point we heard is
that Flynn has stopped cooperating
what's he ever cooperating with the
Trump administration was he ever trading
information I have to tell you if I were
Trump's lawyer I wouldn't give Flynn one
bit of information but I know there's
always the possibility that he will flip
so I think this story has a lot yet to
be revealed Alan Dershowitz great to see
you thank you so much for joining us
tonight thank you